oh I haven't played a game since I was
born you haven't played a game until you
played
Dead or Alive three extreme fortune in
play
what is your favorite game they do delay
extreme is a fortune you know god damn
[Music]
yes I know were you thinking yes they
did ask me to be a voice factory in this
game now I have the Japanese version for
some goddamn reason I paid way too much
don't ask how much I paid for this it
doesn't have english sub party we're
going to have to play this in Japanese
it's confusing it's [ __ ] hell but
like it's such a bizarre game to play
that it just makes it even better now
I'm sure there is some sort of story to
this game oh wait she's 147 centimeter
she's a goddamn [ __ ] or a
twelve-year-old what the [ __ ]
she's fingering she's fingering what's
it what is this game I haven't even
started yet Oh oh my god
150 with those she weighs 45 killers I
think we know where most of the weight
is oh my god I can't it's just too much
too much man oh my god how do I pick
there's so many good options if you ever
feel like you want to not live anymore
I really recommend just firing up this
game and see it's even change you've
changed your mind afterwards here we go
but I have no idea what's happening but
I love it I thought this was a
volleyball game I see two volleyball but
I don't see a court oh my god
am I supposed to answer that well I hope
I don't offend her let's go over this
one I think I heard condom I think we're
about to play the game let's play that
poor how am I supposed can someone
translate this what is happening that a
loading screen or was that the day one
day one evening okay so now we can so we
can go to do different things the world
okay I get a word holiday let's go to
Nikki Beach what is she what is she
doing I mean Kyle I NIC oh ho
this is ridiculous Ainsley this is
ridiculous stop just please please
please I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna die
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna live anymore
I don't understand I don't understand
how this is a game I am just looking at
enemy bait you like it miss yes leave a
like for enemy hey it's a prayer it's a
presence everyone
and now I will choose to decapitate her
[Music]
Ohio's i'ma thank you everybody clap it
up day to day - how do you play
volleyball I swear to god it that's a
volleyball
okay let's do it let's do it let's just
do it
she's not even look talking whatever
what is happening what is happening what
is this what was that what was it's a
game with no gameplay but it's still the
greatest goddamn game how about we try
one of these options okay she kind of
licks up a little bit doesn't she you
can play two player I think okay so
let's try maybe now there okay X and
circle okay
fruity it says fruity I approve of the
fruit is this is has been put apply
everyone and I give my seal of approval
of the fruit Prudie
oh my god what are they doing why it I
begin it are we gonna I started too
early what was she going oh my god
this is this is the game okay it is the
game after all okay so let's try that
again then I love the atmosphere of the
game like it it's got a good vibe it
makes me feel good it makes me feel warm
just like the sweet release of death
help me help me help okay here we go go
go
crunch crunch rag rug come on don't get
it [ __ ] yeah donkeys ah yes I can hear
you well what a rush
what a rush Oh shame I sure - it's all
about the love friendship and animating
you all I love this those bananas looks
delicious am i right
wow those palm trees are so cool okay
I'm not looking at anything much well
everyone there has been added I think we
could play more I think we should play
more I want to play more I want this
game injected in my blood Creek if I
ever
this is a public legally binding
statement if I ever get in a coma I want
this game to be playing 24/7 and then I
want to stay on life support and I never
want you to wake me up put this game in
VR it's this game out on VR I think this
game is out on beer oh my [ __ ] god
the game is out in VR it's been great I
am just going to [ __ ] off for this is
this has been all I'm doing as PewDiePie
I'm officially quitting it's been
it's been quite a journey which we've
gone through a lot of things together
and a lot of things has happened I just
realized that all I really care about
from now on if to play oh whoa oh not at
all I almost died I'm happy to be alive
everyone I'm happy to be a lab all right
let's do one more vacation because I oh
my god
how old is she like I it feels okay
never mind come on we got to win there
come on
go faster what are you doing god damn it
[ __ ] dick [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
dead to me dick disgust me alright what
else can we do
I [ __ ] love the music let's go and
have let's go to that Sports Center
oh my god we can buy a new hello hello
hello the customized sequence I don't
have enough but [ __ ] sake man
all right I'm gonna play the game until
we have it no no no no you can buy I'm
water my long
I just bought a water melone and a pizza
yes I wrapped the pizza did I just like
did I just make a pizza into a wrapping
gift that's amazing
let's try at that pool laughs what okay
so we got to hit the command your Lanyon
oh [ __ ] this looks tricky okay here we
go oh my god this so shut up oh it's wet
now oh no what I want to get one chance
shut the [ __ ] up this game just makes me
happy I don't know what to shut the [ __ ]
up all right you're spoken when spot you
speak when spoken to
hey by the way I have a gift for you
it's a it's a pista is it I got you up
would you like a piece that I brought
you again always put the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is this I can play black oh this
game just gets better and better
are we in bikinis okay my bed a nice
classy all right we got sixteen I'll say
oh hey we won it's kind of hard to play
this game when you don't [ __ ] know
what the [ __ ] you're doing let's just go
all in all right we're five we're five
hit hit me twelve hit me seventeen one
day come on you got da all right I'm on
a roll I'm gonna [ __ ] you keep going oh
I'm gonna buy a big 88 come on come on
blackjack oh oh my god oh my god alright
we stop now we [ __ ] stop no joke stop
we can buy the bikini now we can buy the
bikini we can booty knee would you give
to the pizza
[Music]
I've always wanted to get my enemy
girlfriend a big one with creamer a peek
there you go
I gave her a piece the greatest gift of
love a piece this game understands human
interaction I don't want to play I
already played I already played all
right [ __ ] you game if I knew like how
to progress so now the question it if
you like the pizza if you're going to
give us something back ok I want to do
the whole game again because I [ __ ]
suck today I want to do a hundred part
series this is my new happy will I'm
doing hundred part series of this game
no joke oh my god are we going to bump
but we're gonna bump but we're gonna I
got no sleep bumper take sex rich take
this [ __ ] that's why my bully win and
oh yeah yeah yeah tell you haha ok [ __ ]
you want [ __ ] you up every time for
Chuck sports shop let's buy hello hello
hello yes yes yes shut the [ __ ] up I
have enough money I know I have enough
money I was on a [ __ ] roll with that
black sack
I can't afford it are you kidding me no
no no don't give the pizza box to her
what are you doing no no no you have not
deserved a pizza box it drives me crazy
[Music]
she can't just end it I don't know where
what the hell I was playing was on day
three I never got today so we got yep
do not tell Marzia about this video but
if you enjoyed leave a thumbs up and
that take away and I'd look good
youtubers like me anymore and check out
another video they're probably going to
monetize this one